hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 30 y vamos a hablar
sobre las reacciones de neutralización
que también las conocemos como
reacciones ácido base y para poder
entenderlas primero vamos a entender uno
de los elementos más abundantes en el
universo el 90% de los átomos son
hidrógeno el hidrógeno consiste en un
protón y un electrón y recuerden que el
protón tiene una carga positiva y el
electrón tiene una carga negativa
entonces si le quitamos el electrón nos
queda un protón así que esto lo podemos
llamar unión de hidrógeno que tiene una
carga positiva o simplemente un protón
los dos significan lo mismo y esto es
muy importante cuando hablamos de las
reacciones de neutralización vamos a ver
el agua es una sustancia anfo ctera eso
significa que puede actuar como un ácido
o como una base y más específicamente
puede actuar como un ácido de bronce
laurie o como una base de bronces de
dlouhy y eso qué significa bueno un
ácido te brondsted lowry dona un protón
a la base es decir que un nacido siempre
dona su protón a la base y esa es la
mejor definición para identificar a un
nacido y a una base entonces cuando el
protón es transferido a eso se le conoce
como reacción de neutralización y esto
sólo ocurre en solución acuosa y también
necesitamos identificar cuál es el ácido
y cuál es la base o dicho de otra forma
cuál es el par conjugado ácido base y
también usando esta definición podemos
saber cuál es la fuerza del ácido y de
la base o por lo menos podemos saber qué
significa esa fuerza entonces el agua es
muy interesante pero una de las razones
por la que es interesante es porque si
tenemos suficiente agua el agua puede
empezar a transferir protones aquí
tenemos una carga negativa
y una carga positiva en el protón
entonces algunas veces uno de estos
protones puede cambiar de lugar formando
así el ión hidronew que tiene una carga
positiva y el ión hidróxido que tiene
una carga negativa entonces usando la
definición de brondsted lowry para
definir a un ácido y a una base lo que
hacemos es transferir un protón del
ácido a la base así es cómo definimos
cuál es el ácido y cuál es la base ahora
algo que también es muy interesante
sobre el agua es que puede funcionar
tanto como un ácido o también como una
base y de dónde viene esta definición
bueno los científicos brondsted en
dinamarca y laurie en inglaterra
descubrieron esto al mismo tiempo y por
eso les dieron crédito a los dos cuando
se creó la teoría entonces lo que
hacemos es tomar un ácido y una base y
luego transferimos el protón del ácido a
la base otra forma de decirlo sería que
él
ha sido que tiene al protón transfiere
ese protón a la base entonces al mezclar
un ácido con una base que es lo que
conocemos como neutralización se forma
una base conjugada y un ácido conjugado
y observen que esta es una reacción
reversible lo que significa que podemos
ir en ambas direcciones por eso tenemos
una flecha apuntando hacia los dos lados
y un ejemplo de esto es el ácido acético
con agua
entonces si el ácido acético reacciona
con el agua podemos tomar este protón
del ácido acético y donárselo al agua
porque en este caso el ácido acético es
el ácido y el agua sería la base y
recuerden que lo interesante sobre el
agua es que puede servirnos como un
ácido pero también como una base
tómense un momento y traten de descubrir
si en este caso el agua actúa como un
ácido o una base y aquí es un ácido o
una base si es necesario regresen a la
definición recuerden que un ácido es
algo que siempre dona un protón y una
base es algo que siempre recibe o acepta
el protón entonces en la primera
reacción tenemos ácido clorhídrico y
agua ya saben cuál es cuál bueno el
ácido es el ácido clorhídrico y la base
es el agua el agua está recibiendo el
protón por lo tanto actúa como una base
entonces lo que ocurre es que perdemos
el protón del ácido clorhídrico y así
transformamos la base conjugada cloruro
y como el agua gana un protón entonces
formamos el ácido conjugado ahora en el
caso de abajo tenemos amoniaco y agua y
miren aquí el agua funciona como un
ácido porque está donando un
y el amoniaco acepta ese protón así se
forma el ácido conjugado y la base
conjugado
ahora cuando hablamos de un ácido fuerte
o de una base fuerte por ejemplo veamos
el caso de un ácido muy fuerte como el
ácido clorhídrico si agregamos ácido
clorhídrico al agua el ácido clorhídrico
se va a disociar completamente es decir
que tenemos los protones y los iones
cloruro por separado y por eso decimos
que es un ácido fuerte y observen que la
flecha se encuentra en una sola
dirección y este protón no se quedará
nada más flotando por ahí porque
rápidamente se combinará con el agua
para formar el hidrógeno además de que
no podemos tener protones libres
entonces este es un ácido fuerte ahora
vamos con algo que sea un ácido medio
podemos ver el ejemplo del ácido acético
aquí se transfieren los protones al agua
pero también se pueden regresar al ácido
por eso tenemos una flecha que va en
ambas direcciones y finalmente si
analizamos el bicarbonato el bicarbonato
tiene
más a aceptar el protón y por eso
decimos que es un ácido débil y también
podemos agregar una flecha del otro lado
porque al aumentar la fuerza ácida
claramente podemos ver que disminuye la
fuerza básica y viceversa esa es la
teoría de brondsted laurie sobre ácidos
y bases y así es como podemos
identificarlos en una reacción de
neutralización lo aprendieron
aprendieron a identificar cuál es el
ácido cuál es la base y pueden saber
cuáles son los pares conjugados
recuerden siempre hay que identificar en
dónde está el protón y a dónde se va así
sabrán cuál es el ácido y cuál es la
base